thank you now CCSD high school students
volunteer as tribute for Hunger Games
the exhibitions a sustainable art
competition led by CCSD and City Neon so
sonal you're with CCSD and we've got Zoe
here with City Neon and City Neon you
guys are the producers of The Hunger
Games the exhibition right yes that's
correct so tell us why you guys decided
to join forces well of course we're the
owners of The Hunger Games experience at
the MGM Grand hotel and casino and this
year is also the 10th year anniversary
of the film franchise it's been 10 years
oh my gosh it makes me feel kind of old
yes exactly and so with that we wanted
to do something to give back to our
community so we've met up with suno from
the Clark County School District and
what I learned is that there's a lot of
creative Talent out here in southern
Nevada so yeah I mean that's why we
wanted to do this we designed this
platform for the students to Showcase
their talent that is awesome so how do
you feel you know at CCSD having a major
Vegas attraction you know want to
support the local talent in your school
district yeah I I think it's a
tremendous opportunity for the students
to unless like Zoe like Zoe was saying
to really showcase their creativity
their Innovation and really it empowers
the student right they're going to show
off their designs and their their ideas
about examples showing right now yeah on
how it relates to the Hunger Games and
and many of them probably honestly
probably didn't even watch the movie in
the theater right so they're kind of
reading about the books and and kind of
reliving that story and you know that
story of Hunger Games Katniss and that
empowerment and really coming out of
poverty and and succeeding and making
real life change it's just a tremendous
opportunity for sure and really quick
just Define sustainable art so what it
really means is that the materials that
we use has to be sustainable or recycled
so we really don't want to see kids
shopping at Target or Walmart or the
materials right gotcha gotcha okay
that's just one of the rules but where
can they find out more information and
get involved I mean we can definitely
look at all the rules we have it all on
our website The Hunger Games the
exhibition.com so the full set of rules
are over there but please the most
important rule is that this is a
sustainable art contest and the
materials we will really eyeball
everything okay and there and there
there's something at stake here they're
winning some money right the winner yeah
yeah exactly yeah the top prize is a
thousand dollar cash prize for a student
however you know in in working with City
Neon we also wanted to reward the
teachers as well because the teachers
are really supporting and encouraging
the students to really kind of let their
ideas flourish and to empower them so
the teachers also get a thousand dollar
cash prize and the winning project will
also uh that class will have an
opportunity to do a field trip Excursion
I love it to the Hunger Games so yeah I
got to cut you guys off that is so cool
we're so excited to see who wins and
what the art that students make but we
will be right back here online